- If you're afraid of coming
down and going and swimming
in the ocean because of
sharks, you should be terrified
to make a piece of toast.
400 people died last year
from defective toasters,
whereas less than 10 did from sharks.
This is the first large
shark expedition like this
in the Western Gulf.
We'll be tagging hammerhead
sharks, tiger sharks,
and mako sharks, trying
to understand how they're
leveraging the gulf and
their birthing, mating,
and full migratory patterns.
We'll be getting up every
day just before dawn,
the fishing team will be
going out, getting all of our
lines rigged and ready to go,
and then we'll get the ship
in position with the lift in the water.
And we'll be looking to capture,
bring sharks back to the
lift, lift them up out of the water, and
once we do that, a whole team
of scientists from a half-
dozen institutions will
circle around the shark.
And we'll conduct 12 research
projects in about 15 minutes,
then release the shark and
open source the tracking
to the world so that
everyone can follow it.
What we're finding is that
these massive sharks have
huge, huge movements across the ocean.
We have one of these white sharks, Lydia,
who's traveled over 35,000
miles in just two years.
Very, very regular for
these sharks to be swimming
1,000 miles a month, which
is why it's so important
to figure out where they go.
We're losing 200,000
sharks a day for shark fin soup—
100 million a year.
You know, people need to
understand an ocean with no
sharks means an ocean with
no fish; they are the lion,
the balance keeper for the
ocean, and if they are not there,
the whole food chain collapses.
This is a simple battle;
we've got to solve the puzzle
of these sharks’ lives to
make sure they flourish and
make a difference for the future.
(soft music)